y
[Música]
en eeuu tienen lugar más de 300
movilizaciones en contra de la posible
decisión de la corte suprema- que podría
anular el derecho al aborto a nivel
federal
las marchas llegan tras la filtración de
un borrador de sentencia del tribunal
supremo que aparentemente acabaría con
esta protección ampliamos desde
washington
se cumplen 80 días de guerra en ucrania
y continúa la ofensiva de las fuerzas y
ucranianas que han forzado la retirada
de las tropas rusas de la ciudad de jarc
y la segunda más grande del país las
autoridades de kiev aseguran que el
ejército de moscú ahora concentra su
ofensiva en la región de donges donde
continúan los ataques
el presidente finlandés conversó hoy con
su homólogo ruso y le anunció sus planes
de unirse a la otan vladimir putin
señaló que sería un grave error el
kremlin asegura que tomara medidas de
precaución adecuadas en la alianza
atlántica- despliega fuerzas e
infraestructura nuclear más cerca de sus
fronteras analizamos
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 soy rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en eeuu
donde se están llevando a cabo más de
300 movilizaciones a favor del derecho
al aborto legal el descontento social ha
crecido en el país luego que se filtrara
un borrador de sentencia de la corte
suprema de justicia que podría anular la
icónica sentencia del caso roe versus
wait que protege el derecho a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo a
nivel federal nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal bàsquet no se
ampliaba la información
hola yo lo saludo desde la avenida
pensilvania esa por donde transita la
marcha a favor del aborto acá en
washington la alcaldía dio permiso para
que 17 mil personas salieran hoy a
manifestarse a favor del aborto y en
contra de la decisión que eventualmente
tomaría la corte suprema de justicia de
eeuu de prohibir el aborto esto a
principios de julio como se conoció a
partir de la información filtrada miles
de manifestantes sacan washington
entonces y en las principales ciudades
del país se calcula que hay 380 eventos
similares a este hoy en todo el país y
entonces esta marcha llegará hasta la
corte suprema donde se termina la esta
avenida pensilvania y allá para andy
este llamado a la acción por parte de
los magistrados de que por favor
protejan el derecho al aborto la corte
suprema de justicia está al frente del
capitolio donde también quieren
compartir este mensaje de proteger el
aborto después de que la semana pasada
precisamente se conociera que el senado
no va a tomar medidas para proteger el
aborto en eeuu casablanca ha dicho que
apoya este tipo de iniciativas este tipo
de marchas pero muchos analistas y
críticos dicen que ya es muy tarde y muy
poco lo que puede hacer el ejecutivo
teniendo en cuenta la resistencia que
hay en la corte suprema de justicia y en
el senado
y en ucrania concretamente en la ciudad
de jarc y la segunda más importante del
país tras semanas de intenso asedio por
parte de las fuerzas rusas las tropas
ucranianas han logrado replegar a los
soldados de rusia según medios
internacionales el ejército de moscú
concentra su ofensiva en retomar
terrenos que ha ido perdiendo en la
región del donbass veamos más detalles
en el informe en este pequeño suburbio
del noreste de jarquín muchas cosas han
quedado reducidas de escombros las
tropas rusas han sido expulsadas de la
zona y los residentes han empezado a
regresar dichas zonas napster y libertad
ahora no nos bombardean sólo se dispara
nuestra artillería no hay impacto sobre
nosotros por lo tanto se puede vivir en
paz el agua y la electricidad han sido
recolectadas
lucy liu moto jarquín la segunda ciudad
de ucrania está situada apenas a 40 km
de la frontera rusa y fue uno de los
primeros objetivos de los ataques rusos
en las últimas semanas las tropas
ucranianas empezaron a alejar a las
fuerzas rusas en la región hasta el
punto de que los residentes han
comenzado a regresar a la ciudad y sus
alrededores comensal típica en el
noreste de la ciudad dondequiera que
mires se puede recordar que hace sólo
unos días esto era parte de la primera
línea esto era un campo de batalla había
explosiones muy fuertes todos los días a
todas horas algunas personas al
principio querían quedarse aquí y
protegiéndose en los refugios
subterráneos pero luego se dieron cuenta
de que era imposible quedarse aquí más
allá al este de la ciudad el pueblo de
vilque ipca los ciudadanos que viven
allí tratan de seguir adelante con sus
vidas pero quedó en su memoria los
recuerdos de la presencia rusa los
soldados rusos vivían aquí solían dormir
presuntamente durante la noche se
escondían aquí es como un búnker para
esconderse de los bombardeos dormían
aquí hay una cocina solían comer aquí lo
intentaban al menos
jarquín y sus alrededores tenían 15
millones de habitantes antes de la
invasión rusa ahora es menos de un
tercio de eso y cuando se cumplen 80
días de ofensiva rusa en ucrania y en el
donbass reportes internacionales indican
que rusia busca acortar las líneas de
suministro del ejército ucraniano desde
grama torres catalina gómez ángel
enviada especial de france 24 nos
explica lo que se vive en el terreno la
batalla por la provincia de lugansk en
esta región del donbass continúa en este
día número 80 los bombardeos y los
ataques continúan especialmente en esa
región cercana ávila jurídica y a pesar
de que las fuerzas ucranianas han
logrado detener el avance especialmente
esos tanques rusos y destruir los
puentes militares que han tratado de
crear las fuerzas rusas pues siguen
habiendo ataques y bombardeos
sin embargo hablando con militares ellos
dicen que están poniendo toda la
posibilidad de la cantidad de tanques y
armamento pesado para defender esta
región es increíble y es que para ellos
es fundamental especialmente por razones
también económicas a que hay grandes
industrias unas de ellas en esta ciudad
de crematorios pero también grandes
minas que son importantísimas para la
economía del país al igual que campos
cultivados sin embargo también nos dicen
que de esta provincia si la mantienen
depende el futuro también de otras
ciudades como ni prosap orilla que
también son estratégicas en la economía
del país especialmente por sus fábricas
así que dicen que ellos en ningún
momento van a ceder por la pelea por
esta región del donbass porque es
estratégica para mantener a ucrania
unida iu a flote
mientras tanto en quiere el presidente
de volodymyr selenski recibió al líder
republicano del senado de eeuu mitch
mcconnell quien llegó junto con una
comisión de legisladores el mandatario
señaló que se trata de una poderosa
señal de apoyo bipartidista a ucrania
por parte del congreso de los eeuu y el
pueblo estadounidense asimismo señaló
que el gobierno de washington le está
ayudando a ucrania a luchar por los
valores y las libertades democráticas
por su parte el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de rusia serguéi lávrov habló
en el consejo de diplomacia y defensa
del país allí aseguró que occidente ha
comenzado una guerra híbrida contra
rusia y que es difícil para decir cuánto
durará los esfuerzos para aislar a rusia
aseguró están condenados al fracaso
en el occidente en conjunto nos ha
declarado una guerra híbrida total y es
difícil predecir cuánto durará todo esto
pero está claro que las consecuencias
las sentirán todos sin excepción hicimos
todo lo posible para evitar un
enfrentamiento directo pero ahora que el
desafío ha sido lanzado por supuesto que
lo aceptamos no somos ajenos a las
sanciones casi siempre estuvieron ahí de
una forma u otra absoluta y en medio de
la tensión por el deseo de ingreso de
finlandia en la otan el presidente
finlandés conversó con vladimir putin
para comunicarle los planes de su
gobierno a su vez el mandatario ruso le
respondió que abandonar el estatus
neutral sería un grave error moscú
advirtió que tomara lo que califica de
medidas de precaución adecuadas si la
alianza despliega fuerzas e
infraestructura nuclear más cerca de la
frontera de rusia para analizar esta
información hablamos con alejandro
corbacho director del observatorio de
seguridad y defensa de la universidad
cema en argentina señor corbacho
bienvenida france24 en que cambia el
tablero geopolítico la probable adhesión
de finlandia y suecia la otan finlandia
recordemos es un país fronterizo con
rusia
bueno él es serio para rusia y pone más
de manifiesto que la política de putin
de por la cual justifica el ataque a
ucrania la invasión ucrania que es
frenar la expansión de la otan está
yendo en contra está siendo un bumerán y
esto hace que si si finlandia ingresa a
la otan y suecia lo mismo se
incorporarían otros dos estados y como
usted decía finlandia es un país
fronterizo eso sería un revés muy serio
para putin por supuesto como usted
ustedes están señalando este las
posiciones putin de amenaza que eso
sería gravísimo lo cual es cierto y que
tomaría medidas eso no sabemos qué es lo
que puede ocurrir y por otro lado
finlandia no sabemos si va a desplegar
armas nucleares o no pero digamos
todavía se está discutiendo si finlandia
va a entrar porque para ingresar a la
otan tiene que ser aceptado por
unanimidad y turquía que es el país que
es un país miembro de la otan y de los
iniciales se opone por ahora no está muy
de acuerdo su presidente ha expresado
que no no muy positivo como usted bien
ha dicho la entrada se podría haber
truncada por un posible veto de turquía
que exige a ambos países dejar de apoyar
al pkk el partido de los trabajadores
del kurdistán sería fácil que se llegara
a un acuerdo respecto a este tema y que
supondría esto para turquía y el
conflicto aún latente en el norte de
siria y el kurdistán iraquí
bueno vemos como el mundo globalizado
está muy muy conectado y finlandia se
piensa que las situaciones es muy seria
la amenaza la percibe como muy muy grave
podría llegar a cambiar está su postura
y buscar que turquía al lado lo logró
apoye no eso siempre el miedo y el
terror son los que está funcionando en
este momento esto ha hecho que finlandia
y suecia que históricamente se
mantuvieron neutrales abandonen la
neutralidad o sea el nivel de brutalidad
que se está viendo que despliega rusia
en el conflicto realmente hace que los
los vecinos se sientan inseguros
para obtener el paraguas nuclear o el
paraguas de defensa de la otan para
finlandia parece ser que es un valor
importantísimo con lo cual ar ha
abandonado su tradicional postura
y volviendo a rusia si atacará a suecia
o finlandia durante el proceso de
adhesión la otan podría activar el
artículo 5 de asistencia mutua o algún
mecanismo similar de respuesta en otras
palabras qué posibilidades hay que rusia
y la otan se enfrenten directamente
no creo que eso vaya primero no creo que
vaya a suceder y segundo si
putin invade finlandia en este momento
bueno este finlandia va a tener que
defenderse por sí mismo no no no el
artículo 5 es ataque a un miembro de la
otan esto quedó quedó claro me parece
que lo que a lo que ha quedado también
claro es que todos aquellos territorios
que están linderos
a rusia que no están protegidos por lo
tanto corren peligro entonces la idea
es para los finlandeses lograr el
ingreso lo más rápido posible para
obtener ese paraguas de lo contrario
todavía no están bajo esa protección y
eso es para ellos y ellos lo perciben
como muy muy peligroso muy riesgoso
señor corbacho muchas gracias pueden
analizar con nosotros esta situación
entre rusia y finlandia y suecia gracias
de nuevo y pasamos a nuevos temas porque
las autoridades peruanas informaron que
presentaron una demanda judicial contra
la compañía repsol por 4.500 millones de
dólares la medida se produce cuatro
meses después del derrame de petróleo
ocurrido en la refinería de la pampilla
que afectó a las costas peruanas desde
el hima francisco zacarías corresponsal
de france 24 nos daba más detalles
el gobierno peruano demanda a la empresa
española repsol por 4 mil 500 millones
de dólares en representación de 700.000
personas afectadas por el derrame de
petróleo ocurrido el 15 de enero en el
mar revienten y al norte de lima el
instituto nacional de defensa de la
competencia y de la protección de la
propiedad intelectual indecopi presentó
ante una corte la demanda civil de
indemnización por daños y perjuicios
contra repsol y otras cinco compañías
aliadas el caso busca una valorización
abstracta de tres mil millones de
dólares por los daños causados y 1500
millones de dólares por el daño moral a
los consumidores usuarios y terceros
afectados julian palacín presidente de
indecopi el organismo que llevará a la
corte a repsol dijo que esta demanda
podría generar jurisprudencia en casos
de derrame de petróleo que producen
perjuicios por contaminación del medio
ambiente este domingo se cumplen 4 meses
del derrame de 12 mil barriles de
petróleo de repsol en el mar relima que
impactó a más de 15 mil hectáreas 46
playas 2 áreas naturales y dejó más de
600 especies muertas este es uno de los
peores desastres ambientales ocurridos
en el litoral peruano que también ha
cobrado un alto costo social dejando a
miles de pescadores y comerciantes sin
empleo en noticias de américa latina' el
cuerpo de marcelo pecci y el fiscal
antimafia paraguayo asesinado en
colombia mientras disfrutaba de su luna
de miel llegó a asunción la capital de
paraguay y en medio de un fuerte
dispositivo de seguridad allí fue
recibido y honrado por familiares amigos
y autoridades del país el presidente de
paraguay mario abdo benítez decretó en
la noche del viernes tres días de duelo
y cerramos con la victoria del liverpool
del colombiano luís díaz al cen la f a
cup de inglaterra el año que el torneo
cumplía 150 años los reds se llevaron la
victoria por penaltis frente al chelsea
en un partido que acabó 0-0 y en el que
destacó luis díaz en el ataque del
liverpool por el flanco izquierdo
positiva victoria para el liverpool
antes de la final de champions frente al
real madrid por su contra se estrella su
estrella el egipcio mohamed salah acabó
el partido lesionado con estas imágenes
acabamos este informativo sigan
conectados
[Música]